person was killed when a car dealership
was also hit
the leaders of palestine's rival
political parties are meeting in Algeria
for two days of talks on reconciliation
this is the latest effort to solve a
more than decade-long Rift between Hamas
and fatah after previous agreements
failed Hamas has governed the Gaza Strip
since defeating president Mahmoud
abbas's fatal party in parliamentary
elections in 2006. armed conflict broke
out after fatah refused to recognize the
results and that ended when Hamas forced
fata out of Gaza entirely since then the
Palestinian leadership has been divided
the fatal-led Palestinian Authority
governing the West Bank on the one side
and Hamas running the Gaza Strip on the
other
well despite several rounds of
negotiations the sticking points remain
so let's go through them the most
contentious is the future of hamas's 25
000 strong armed Wing the qasan brigades
both fatan Israel want it completely
disarmed the sides also haven't been
able to agree on the payment of salaries
to 30 000 civil workers hired to run the
Hamas government in Gaza the government
hasn't enough income to fully pay their
wages
both sides will also have to agree on
how to move forward with long overdue
Palestinian elections they would be the
first to be held since the vote in 2006.
we're covering this from both sides the
occupied West Bank where Anita Ibraham
is standing by and
gazaed let's go to you first
we've seen attempts of reconciliation
before they haven't worked so are people
in Gaza optimistic about this one what
are their expectations
on the contrary actually we've spoken to
several people in the street actually
this morning asking them what they think
and what they hope of these recent talks
about the reconciliation in Algeria and
most people were very uh pessimistic
about this this round of talks they say
that this internal division which has
been almost 16 years now needs more than
just talks to solve the disagreements
the huge disagreements between fatah and
Hamas especially that they have seen
that through the past years many of
these talks have failed while the
disagreements were a lot more less than
what they are on the real ground today
also people here see that Hamas is
control over the Gaza Strip is not
something that it would easily let go of
off especially that the fundamental
disagreements between fatah Hamas uh
where uh fata is not also going to be
compromising uh with the presidential
elections uh the reorganizing of the
Palestinian Liberation Organization like
Hamas demands and many other demands
that both sides have demanded the
Palestinian Street here in Gaza sees
that it is almost impossible to reach a
positive result over these uh
disagreements
all right let's go to Nida now you're in
Ramallah in the occupied West Bank Nida
how seriously should Palestinians be
taking this attempt this latest attempt
at reconciliation
let me tell you that recent polls we've
been looking at suggest that two-thirds
of Palestinians do not believe that
these reconciliation efforts are going
to be leading towards a success or that
it would change the reality on the
ground Palestinians believe that the
both parties have vested interests in
keeping the situation and the status quo
as is because both parties have a
certain control over their respective
territories but many will tell you that
whatever control the Palestinian
Authority has in the occupied West Bank
or Hamas has in the besieged Gaza Strip
the ultimate control really is in the
hands of Israel because the Gaza Strip
is still besieged the occupied West Bank
is still has daily rate has illegal
Israeli settlements expanding so the
reality on the ground suggests that
whatever control they have it's very
very limited now it's this is not the
first meeting for a Reconciliation no
only that there has been dozens and
dozens of agreements between the two
parties namely the Cairo agreement that
had mechanisms on how to resolve the
issue but Palestinians would tell you
that both parties are comfortable in
their situation and they would tell you
also that Israel is the one that is
standing to win from the current
division between Palestinians Ned
Abraham in Ramallah thank you very much
thank you to you as well
families are holding their final prayers